هذا ما فعلته ألف ليلة وليلة
في سجن سعودي
بالناشطة الحقوقية لجان
الحفف ، التي
دعت من أجل تمكين النساء من
القيادة ،
تم إلقاء القبض عليها في مايو 2018 أخيرًا وتم إطلاق سراحها يوم
الأربعاء
على الرغم من رفضها التراجع عن
مزاعم
التعذيب التي قامت بها  الحكومة تنفي
سعادتها للرئيس جو بايدن
لأنها كانت مدافعة قوية عن
حقوق المرأة
وكان إطلاق سراحها هو الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب
فعله
أثناء مثولها أمام المحكمة أواخر العام الماضي
،
صُدمت عائلتها من حالتها التي رأى والداي أنها
كانت
ضعيفة للغاية من أن جسدها كان يرتجف.
وهذا صوتها أيضًا ، لكن حتى
مع ذلك
كانت لا تزال مركزة جدًا
وأرادت قراءة دفاعها بالكامل
عنها ونشطاء آخرون يتعرضون
للصعق بالكهرباء
بالغرق بالغرق والضرب
وحرمانهم من النوم وإطعامهم قسرًا
الآن على تويتر تطالب عائلتها
بجميع التهم الموجهة إليها  تم إسقاطها
ومحاسبة معذبيها ، ضغطت
وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية من
أجل إطلاق سراحها ، ولا أريد
أن
أعلق دوافع على  سلوك أي
حكومة
أخرى ما يمكنني قوله هو ما قلته
سابقًا ، سيكون الإصدار
في هذه الحالة تطورًا إيجابيًا للغاية ،
وهو أمر نرحب
به ، وهو شيء
ضغطنا عليه لأننا ننهي كل
الدعم الأمريكي
للعمليات الهجومية والحرب  في اليمن
بالفعل منذ أن تولى الرئيس جو بايدن المنصب
من سلفه ،
تشهد المملكة العربية السعودية تغييرًا جذريًا في المواقف
الداعمة للحقوق العالمية التي
تحترم سيادة القانون
ومعاملة كل شخص بكرامة.
أعتقد
أن التهم الموجهة إليه تتعلق بمحاولة
تجنيد أشخاص في مناصب حساسة
في الحكومة من أجل
الحصول على وثائق حساسة ومنحهم
سلطات معادية في ذلك
الوقت ، قال وزير الدولة
للشؤون الخارجية في البلاد إن السعودية لن تخضع للخضوع
الدولي  الضغط للإفراج عن اللوجان ،
فنحن لسنا خاضعين للضغط ، ولا
نسمح للناس بالتخلص من اللوجان
للضغط علينا من أجل القيام بأشياء
تتعارض مع مصالحنا ، ليس من الواضح
ما إذا كانت العقول
قد تغيرت الآن ولكن في الأسبوع الماضي
، استقبل العديد من المعتقلين البارزين الآخرين بشكل
مفاجئ يوم الخميس الماضي
ناشطان سعوديان هما د.
محتجزًا لمدة
673 يومًا ،
تم الإفراج عنه بكفالة بانتظار المثول أمام المحكمة
يوم الأحد على النعمة ، وهو مراهق
عندما تم القبض عليه لمشاركته في
احتجاج مناهض للحكومة في عام 2012 ،
وتم تخفيف حكم الإعدام الصادر بحقه إلى 10
سنوات على
الأرجح في وقت لاحق من هذا العام
ويوم الاثنين.  أعلن ولي
العهد
محمد بن سلمان بن سلمان عن
مسودة إصلاحات جزئية لتحسين
حقوق الإنسان ، ورد في بيان حكومي أن
الرئيس
الفرنسي إيمانويل ماكرون رحب بالإفراج عن لوجان ، ودعا كبير المدافعين عن حقوق الإنسان في الأمم المتحدة
السعودية إلى إطلاق سراح جميع
المسجونين الآخرين بسبب عملهم في مجال حقوق الإنسان ،
نيك روبرتسون.  لندن